[Music]
foreign
I'll make some sandwiches I want mac and
cheese we should eat fast but my club's
starting soon
you can't eat if this is the last month
I've ever I'm too nervous I can't do
this mac and cheese sounds great
what do you want Casey
anything
lake trout a bunch of it gross
how about you Gerald
stroganoff the creamy kind
how about you
[Music]
I'm fasting
what's the matter with everyone eat
maybe we should check Media Matters for
mug Club
I am not checking Media Matters for mug
Club
Casey had a bad feeling
what was they doing hit peace online
Club well they don't get enough people
to join
I'm not checking Media Matters from mug
Club in case he doesn't have ESP now eat
I hate you
that's fine
you let Joe get AIDS then again
I am not wasting one more minute of my
life on Media Matters
not one more minute understood
that we're going to enjoy this meal
before this stream no one can stop us
from enjoying this meal before this
dream so enjoy it
stop crying Stephen stop yelling at him
it broke my mug
since none of you are excited for the
streamer know how to handle mugs I guess
I'll just have some of everything
foreign
er.com
's access to an unrivaled catalog of
course
all that and everything you see today is
entirely funded by viewers like you for
you for 89 annually join the fight at
lottery.com Mud Club today I hate lake
trout
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
let's start a show with that so uh we
have a lot to get to today obviously
everyone is talking about the Trump
indictment president Trump indictment
some people call him former presidents
some people call them sitting president
I call him sitting president okay fair
here's my question of the day before we
move on because nothing else matters
if we distill it down to one key issue
right you need to cut through the white
noise so let me ask you this
do you think and we're allowed to talk
about this by the way today on YouTube
now finally on Rumble YouTube mug Club
comment do you think that there were
Shenanigans in the election
do you think that there was election
fraud or do you think that there were
election irregularities do you believe
it was the freest and most secure
election of all time comment below
because that's what this is all about
if you believe that if Donald Trump and
Associates believed that then they were
trying to save our Republic yes if they
didn't they were the ones interfering in
election it comes down to that and of
course I think it's pretty damn clear
considering we lived it on Election
night that you know oh the pipe burst no
that's right it didn't burst oh whoops
pelican cases happened we're continued
remember they fact checked us when we
said the suitcase is the votes like not
suitcases they're pelican cases right
different brand what's the difference
humidity control so we'll be talking
about that uh the WF the world economic
form they want you to be allergic to
meat I know what you're thinking Alex
Jones but we actually have the clip of
the man talking about this Germany is
back to their old ways which always has
us concerned and then the Maui fires
look natural disasters I don't think we
should have to say much other than
obviously our hearts break and prayers
to the family unfortunately it's been
blamed on climate change and that's
bullsh so we'll get into some of the
conspiracies regarding that today but
first I have an announcement there's a
of a contest right now so for non-mug
club members who are about to join or
who haven't received your mug yet write
out a tweet so tweet me uh explain what
the idea of mug Club means to you use
the hashtag mug Club giveaway and each
day all the way through this week
possibly next week we will announce a
winner live at the top of the show and
you will get a free year oh very nice by
the way it's not called the Tweet
anymore it's called a post because it's
called an X an X
yeah you've been asked what
what I quote axed I hard X
so stupid uh I'm always concerned that
sometimes I think I have a porn app on
my phone well
just says X all right so uh you hear him
from school you know him you love him
number two in command Gerald hey how are
you sir I am doing well we had some
spicy uh spicy posts sweets whatever
last night it was it was uh yeah you
were going off there on your Twitter a
little bit a little bit uh how are you
doing G Morgan's Twitter is not where
you is that what you would expect I
highly recommend you it's G Morgan Jr
right at G Morgan Jr go check it out
yeah Tim was
and then in third year today you hear
this you know who it is
a bit the Funny Bone Richmond Virginia
this Friday and Saturday that's August
18th and 19th you can follow them on x
at Josh underscore fire Stein how are
you Josh I'm good I'm good good to be
here good to be here I was late today my
headphones are a little bit a little bit
off today but that's okay I can't stop
I'm sorry I can't stop thinking about
Yakuza in that dress
I can't get over it some things can't be
unseen and you don't want to I don't
want to what exactly are you thinking
about Josh oh come on don't worry about
it just he'll exit he'll exit uh if you
could send that to me later I'll uh yeah
X your thoughts
I wasn't going there yeah right okay
so when we had a dinner before the
launch of uh mug Club a very secret
dinner thanks again for those ndas yeah
yeah
Alex Jones was there and he was talking
about how and by the way they're they're
doing this right now they're making
people allergic to meat this comes from
a tick and he starts and we're going
like that sounds like it's probably
partially right uh turns out it was all
correct 100
so again Alex again here is uh a 2016
clip from a world economic form linked
bioethicist his name is Matthew Liao
he's director of the center of bioethics
at NYU okay and uh here's this video now
it's it's surfaced of him uh encouraging
genetically modified humans and talking
about meat allergies so it turns out
that we know a lot about so there we
have this intolerance to uh so I for
example I have milk intolerance I'm uh
and there some people are intolerant to
crayfish so possibly we can pursue human
engineering to make it the case that
we're intolerant to certain kinds of
meat so certain kinds of bovine bovine
proteins and there's actually analogs of
this in light there's this thing called
the lone star tick where if it bites you
you'll become allergic to meat describe
the mechanism so that's something that
we can do very excited about this we can
kind of possibly address really big
world problems with human engineering
well what kind of genetically uh genetic
modifications you need to do to fix your
lisp
I think it could be a lifestyle change
Stephen it's a weird thing like some
people are allergic to milks and some
people are allergic to crayfish
hahaha
fish I don't by the way I just pull out
like milk and some people aren't
allergic to Pineapple something it looks
like he could use a meat yes he does as
well I think he does
I know every now and then Jill just
comes in with a sniper
that's Twitter that's what I'm talking
about listen I'm you fired up I think
it's real what are we about to say there
are the only genetic modification I want
is like a spider human crossover yeah a
whole situation I don't want to have a
yeah
genetically you and David Arquette so
you can have a sequel Perfect
The Tick so think about this though for
a second and this is by the way and you
can comment below they don't want you
eating meat think about impossible
burger and what's it beyond meat there's
Beyond there's impossible it's hard to
keep track but I always find it funny
when you have these vegans who say like
I don't miss meat at all so can you
create something that feels looks and
tastes exactly like what I claim to
dislike
and these things aren't good what's
crazy about this is and there's a
carnivore diet that a lot of people do
by the way and I I I'm not into the what
I would say is sort of cultist dieting
that being said I think generally eat
good food when you're hungry until just
before you're full and that should
include a lot of good quality meat by
the way yeah I think the bulk of your
diet should probably be meat high
protein good fat foods just to be clear
but I don't think you need to be
dogmatic about it that being said there
is some value to the carnivore diet
because this is this is an age-old uh
Elimination Diet that doctors have used
the the one sort of form of I almost say
produce but the one form of food that
people are least allergic to tends to be
red meat yeah saying hey you may have a
food allergy and I don't mean the people
who say they're allergic to gluten right
who are full of it you either have
celiac disease in which case you eat it
and you get violently ill you don't have
a little bit of gluten just like Gerald
doesn't have a little bit of AIDS It's
All or Nothing don't have anything I get
AIDS so the Elimination Diet has always
been red meat because very very few
people it is the food the least likely
to induce some kind of food in town so
there's a dietitian out there a doctor
please comment below let me know if that
is incorrect today in 2023 used to be
the case and now they're talking about
modifying human beings so that they can
develop allergies to boving meat yeah
well to solve climate change because
cows farting is basically you know
destroying the science yeah yeah why are
we trying to give people allergies I
know well so they can't find a way to
make us allergic to fentanyl yes they're
gonna give me my best Alex Jones because
Bill Gates yes he wants people to be
allergic to me because he has a problem
we're going to solve climate change by
this reverse Claritin make you allergic
to everything
you just take one every day or a little
yeah
reverse of that too
oh by the way this is a uh I think
that's Benadryl I don't know
this is a live show Monday through
Friday at 10 A.M Eastern you can watch
it on Rumble of course the free show
doesn't go anywhere uh you also have the
podcast wherever you know you can listen
to the audio version and we do another
full hour uh today of course Every Day
mug Club Friday show you have Alex Jones
you have Nick de Paulo lotter.com okay
Donald Trump
president president Donald Trump I
apologize I was thinking of his son just
saying
I think that's a lie he's been
he's been uh don't question my motives
sorry he's been indicted again all right
everyone's talking about this but
sometimes you need to be too close to
the force to see the trees
um it really does come down to one key
fact here yes this is the fourth
indictment there I don't know how many
charges we'll get to the video there are
100 something counts some of them are so
absurd it it defies all reason this is
absolutely a Witch Hunt just to be clear
and we've experienced this ourselves
this happens all the time they Trump a
bunch of charges so that they can use
those as references to say that you have
been hit with all of these charges this
is what they're doing with Donald okay
all of that is true however this comes
down in Georgia to the quote of fine
these 11 those 11 000 votes okay you may
say that's that sounds bad
but either you believe in what we're
discussing here is what is legally
defensible either you believe that this
was the safest most secure election of
all time right that there were no
Shenanigans going on in Georgia
whatsoever uh in which case president
Donald Trump would have been interfering
in an election
or Donald Trump and his colleagues
believed as all of you did at this point
in time watching right now maybe you
don't today but a lot of people a
majority of Americans believe that some
stuff went down in Georgia some
shenanigans
uh in which case saying Hey look
look at this vote switch here look find
these votes that may have been switched
in which case Donald Trump was trying to
save this Republic the election it does
come down to that did he believe that it
was a completely fair and transparent
election or did he not and you can
comment below if you actually think
genuinely that's my question today in
2023 do you believe that this election
or that last election was uh completely
fair play I like that question too
because it's very it's very clear you
know either you think it's complete
garbage or yeah the best of all time or
you think there's something in there
where maybe in other words in Georgia
with a margin of 0.23 percent and people
continued counting votes in the middle
of the night could you at least allow
for the fact that Donald Trump thought
hey
just like Amy Klobuchar did just like
Jimmy Carter did at one point in time
just like uh just like uh what's her
name in uh Georgia Stacy Abrams yep Star
Trek broad president of the world
Stephen yes president Grimace it's not
like it was California New York or
Washington or it was it's George's right
historically Red State it yeah and by
the way has yet to concede that election
because of issues with the voting
machine so if Donald Trump believes that
there was something afoot there is
nothing illegal or wrong in him saying
hey you know what let's let's get to the
bottom of this so that being said let's
set this up grand jury in Fulton County
uh they just did vote to indict Donald
Trump and this is a very very long clip
so you can hear them lay out the charges
and uh this lady I can't remember who's
in the next clip uh we'll see her but uh
she's long Al Sharpton oh yeah female Al
Sharpton and she went with the uh she
went with the eye shadow color uh bags
under eye bags number two it's gal
Sharpton yes yes that's so stupid I'm
sorry maybe not so sharpen am I right am
I right I'm not though I'm not correct
that's not her name here's the clip
today based on information developed by
that investigation a Fulton County grand
jury returned a true bill of indictment
charging 19 individuals with violations
of Georgia law
arising from a criminal conspiracy to
overturn the results of the 2020
presidential election in this state the
indictment brings felony charges against
Donald John Trump Rudolph William Louis
Giuliani Sydney Catherine Howe every
individual charged in the indictment is
charged with one count of violating
Georgia's racketeer influenced and
corrupt organizations act through
participation
Enterprise
Georgia and elsewhere to accomplish the
illegal goal of allowing Donald J Trump
J Trump to seize the presidential term
of office beginning on January 20th 21.
oh I'm sorry I supposed to care yes yes
oh yeah this is real this is real look
happening you may like Donald Trump you
may not this is just to be
clear whether you like it or not the the
old adage they're going to come for you
next it's absolutely true uh so look to
give you an idea as to how absurd some
of these charges are and Gerald was like
we have to talk about this yeah this was
listed as one of the so count 22 on
honor about a December 2020 on the third
Donald Trump caused to be tweeted from
the Twitter account realdonaldtrump
Georgia here hold on no you have to you
have to say that yeah so this is a this
is one of the charges this one is
charges they're saying that this is some
kind of racketeering or crime where
Donald Trump tweeted Georgia hearings
now on oannn amazing
and that was considered an overt act in
furtherance of conspiracy wow he's
promoting that the hearings are on and
saying it's amazing and they're like
charge number 22. that's the equivalent
to like an old comic I'm like I love
this town yeah I love Bakersfield
silly dude that is so silly that's an
actual cow an actual account that he
said the hearings are on one America
news now how weak are the other charges
that they're like oh we better throw
this in yeah we need to buttress the
point every single tweet he has ever put
out I I think your point is fine look
just it goes down to what he believed
and if he believed that it was amazing
it's fine yeah exactly I guarantee you
he believed it was he's amazing
speaking from the heart actually John
Jacob Jingleheimer Smith's name is in
fact not your name too part of it is it
could be
I don't know wearing pajamas down by the
bay oh boy Where the Watermelons they
grow they grow they grow Vape that's
what people tell me
he's got more than 120 charges against
him they're throwing more against
the wall than Amber Heard on a bender
okay I'm sorry just to be clear she
throws it on beds no
let me read you the case with so uh
charges published by the way
um well the charges that were published
here's something you should know they
were published on the Fulton County
website before the grand jury signed the
indictment also the Grandeur names could
have been leaked just to be clear in
that process that's that's that's a big
deal by the way yeah so that's a problem
so again when you're talking about
conspiracy well this came out before
anyone would have known about it and by
the way as someone who's experienced
this you know that reporters ago and
they offer they offer money they offer
money to people in your circle hey do
you have anything do you have any
private conversation hey do you have a
do you have something that might be
embarrassing a food is he allergic to
crayfish
I'm sorry what is that smash the rumble
button by the way if you were watching
on Rumble and if you're on YouTube smash
the like button what the hell you'll
help with the algorithm I looked at
those charges and one of them was one of
the charges is uh was filed November 5th
2020. yeah before the election
and was it was it quoting something it's
probably quoting something so he claimed
he claimed that he was going to win I'm
not oh that's a charge of the charges he
got legal advice you know what there's
19 people on this indictment because he
got legal advice from people by the way
I'm still a little pissed off Rudy
Giuliani has two middle names yes one is
enough yeah Rudy I know don't be selfish
also Rudolph's not an adult's name
but Rudy is the very best name in sports
history and we know why stop it no but
the point the point is is important he
did say he was going to win that would
be like getting every single athlete
yeah on you know illegal sports betting
because they said they were going to win
a fight yeah yeah exactly what do you
want him to say well I think I'm going
to lose tomorrow but hey go after the
polls we'll see now that would be
something where if he says I'm go I'm
going to lose he go well maybe he's
maybe he's going to take a dive and then
something that you could possibly
control right that would be a great UFC
what do they call it the uh
[Laughter]
I get more money if I go in two
so let's go back here just so you in
case you've forgotten um in February uh
one of the grand jury uh the four person
Emily cores
went on a media tour
talking about
the the process here's that clip did you
personally want to hear people I wanted
to hear from the former president but
honestly I kind of wanted to support the
former president because I got to swear
everybody in and so I thought it'd be
really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump of me looking at him and
being like do you solemnly sweat I'm
beginning to swear him in I just I kind
of just thought that would be an awesome
moment and do you solemnly swear that
you'll stop brushing your hair with a
Spencer's plasma ball no if you're worse
hair for sure
she's allergic to beef she looks like
every song so this is the four person
for the grand for the jury okay and
here's another interview with this uh
distinguished young lady person the
Atlanta Journal Constitution she stated
the late Georgia house Speaker David
Ralston cracked her up she said she
swore him in holding a Ninja Turtle
popsicle she had just received at an ice
cream party thrown by the DA's office
what oh those are so tasty
it's like the soft ones yeah the push-up
one yeah no no I'm sorry nope no I know
what you're talking about the gumball
eyes and you push them I used to get the
Slimer ones from the ice cream truck
sorry then he fondled me
it's mixed memory I take the good with
it two things can be true great slime or
popsicle not so fan of it station so
she was holding a popsicle that she got
from the D.A right before she swore and
Witnesses testifying against Donald
Trump all the references available at
ladder with credit.com just to be clear
now all of this comes down to
[Music]
sorry because I see everyone look what
they're talking about right now on CNN
watch I guarantee you they're not
talking about election Integrity let's
see or a decisive pivot um I think you
would agree but
for the sake of it why not is it just
the looking at the fact that he's
probably crawl back to the underbrush
you shrew so
it comes down to election integrity and
if you believe that we have a problem
now for example if you believe that hey
male and balance played a role or if you
believe that ballot harvesting played a
role or if you believe that the voting
switches the dumps that took place in
the middle of the night by the way we're
allowed to on YouTube discuss election
Integrity now of this now yeah you're
welcome big reason big reason for that
is that we never stopped and they were
tired of suspending us so they said all
right we can't ban them all so thank you
lottery.com it is the tip of the spear
we're never going to stop if we are
removed from YouTube by the way if you
see this uh do you have the YouTube dump
button tool man
I was gonna say if you have it if ever
you see that button out there it means
just head on over to rumble
look at that quick on the draw so um
there's this statement that everyone is
using right it all centers around this
between Donald Trump Georgia Secretary
of State Brad uh Brad raffensberger
Trump stated I just want to find 11 780
votes which one is more than we which
one which is one more than we have
because we won this state now here's the
thing did he believe that he won the
state if so all do you
understand that yeah if he believed that
he won the state now maybe you don't
like Donald Trump
do you believe it's possible that he won
the state do you believe that Donald
Trump believed he won the state I can
tell you this maybe I'll be hauled him
to court for for saying this we've had
Rudy Giuliani on the show that uh Donald
Trump Jr in the show uh we've had many
people said they all 100 believed
that they were illicit tactics uh at
work just to be clear 100 doubt they
never once told us like yeah we're going
to raise a bunch of money on this right
they were all livid the margin of
victory in Georgia was
0.23 percent about 11 779 votes right
which and so the context that you gave
really matters because Donald Trump was
not doing what they say hey go out and
find me votes go ahead and change these
so that I can win he clearly thought
there are way more votes out there for
me than I'm even asking for all we have
to do is find 11 780 illegal votes and I
win the state that's what he was saying
right he's not asking him to go do
something illegal at all and they're
trying to frame it like he is right uh
so let me go through do we have the clip
of us on Election night because I don't
see it there in the in the map no okay
no let me know if they find it so let me
give you some examples here of the
irregularities just in Georgia right
they occurred all across the country
okay like I mean you're used to 100
irregularities you're used to a
six-figure voting dump in the biggest
County in Michigan when the precincts
get boarded up with a
with bristol board and styrofoam and
paper mache
so you can come in at a 99 margin for
Joe but well how did that happen those
are the mail-in votes so 99 yeah yes can
we get a double check on that 99 of
people with homes vote for Joe Biden but
then that guy just says so
Georgia again could Donald Trump have
believed that these were not all
legitimate well remember we were told
that there's a burst pipe right it was
delaying the vote counting in Fulton
County this is overlay six uh B6 so we
were told that and on Election night
hopefully I don't know if the control
room can find this but it's a 12-hour
stream so it's a little bit difficult we
reported on that because it was coming
in we have the original clip of the CBS
news report showing the pipe burst do
you want to play that uh that's not the
yeah so let's show the original CBS clip
but we were live 12 hours that's the
beauty of this being a live show nothing
up Our Sleeve right we have the YouTube
dump button we don't have a a five
minute delay we during the election I
said oh they stopped counting the votes
and so we told you I guess they're not
going to count Georgia here tonight
because there was a pipe that burst so
we'll wait until tomorrow that's what we
were told now we know that it was
irrefutably a lie but here's what
happened at that moment in time this is
from CBS
downtown Atlanta is State Farm Arena
where the Atlanta Hawks play they are
tabulating the absentee ballots of
Fulton County Georgia's most populous
County a water pipe has broken inside
the arena they had counted 86 000
absentee ballots we don't know how many
more they have yet to tabulate but all
the time
we're told by election officials they
may not finish tabulating those votes
for a day or two they may not finish
them for a day or two right then then
you come to find out that nothing no
pipe ever broke and then they tried to
memory hold this stuff and say well we
never said that a pipe what are you
talking about it may take a day or two
because of a pipe hey guess how I know
that government is inefficient so
surveillance video was released of uh
now I want to be very clear here not
suitcases not suitcases pelican cases
because the way they memory hold it was
some people said suitcases when in fact
rather than a pipe being burst in
people's you know they stop tabulating
they did continue tabulating votes and
they did pull cases out from under
tables everything you were told was a
lie but I I I I I I I I I you didn't say
the magic word Pelican case and the
video was released here's the place
where they stopped counting votes at
this point in time because of a burst
pipe
people listening on on the audio first
off go and watch it at Rumble but look
they're pulling these pelican cases
whatever you want to call them
Tupperware someone made a run to The
Container Store they're pulling them out
from underneath the tables and they are
counting them there is no burst pipe
yeah this is at 11. by the way after
they had sent everybody home I believe
at 10 o'clock
and the reasoning was well we needed to
keep counting through the night to make
sure that we got this done okay why did
you send everybody home yeah so some
workers are being told to stop counting
when there was an election supervisor
said go home for the night but then the
Secretary of State's office called right
and told Fulton County to keep counting
yeah
and there were first-hand reports by the
way sworn affidavits of fake pallets and
a ballot shredding now you can see yeah
but those weren't verified well who's
going to verify them that's the issue
that's the Witch Hunt hey I saw a bunch
of fake ballots well I didn't see them
yeah but I'm telling you that they were
there so you should investigate it I
didn't see them well can you check
they're um can you check oh you know
what did I show you our vote Shredder
over here yes why do you hold on why do
you even have one of those right what is
if there is a problem with a ballot
don't you keep it to have evidence that
there was a problem with this ballot so
you can say no no there was a problem we
have a vote Shredder yeah yeah what we
need a vote Splinter I don't think I
don't need that I don't even have a
shredder in my house I have one here
it's very fun it is oh okay maybe that
was it maybe they're gonna have some fun
you know every now and then I play a
game of chicken with right I just I
never Wear Ties but I put on a necktie
and I put it in just goes
stop see what happens
that's fun dangerous so now also uh
recently revealed a raffensberger
um
uh documents information he was aware of
the Dominion voting machine
vulnerabilities but ran with the
machines ah so was everybody by the way
up yeah by the way just to be clear
about that there is a documentary I
don't know if it's still on HBO called
kill chain yep the entire documentary I
think it's called kill chain it is yeah
it's called kill chain the man was
talking about Georgia and he hacked
those voting machines the very same
voting machines used in this election
now he was trying to prove that Stacey
Abrams won and that there was election
interference the entire documentary
focuses on Dominion voting and how
easily they can be compromised and then
you have this guy raffensburg who knew
that and used them anyway
okay so basically uh when you're looking
at asking for a vote totals under
questionable machines right under
questionable circumstances with a tiny
margin of Victory 0.23 saying look the
machines may not work the pipe didn't
burst these votes were counted there was
a chain of custody that was broken
Donald Trump has been indicted for that
for that keep in mind Stacey Abram still
hasn't fully conceded the election
[Laughter]
she's still fighting the good fight yes
she won't let it go
so just where's the indictment where's
the indictment on her she gets a she
gets a walk-on on the CW Network well I
mean her and Hillary Clinton both were
challenging the legitimacy of Elections
by the way why they went a little over
the top the safest and most secure
election in history
but everybody went with that like we all
know that this is the safest and most
secure election in history and you just
heard that like you could play the clips
from everybody saying it across media
and I'm like
does that mean every other election
wasn't safe and secure because this is
the safe no these are safer and more
secure if I walked into a restaurant and
they were like this is the cleanest
safest most edible food you'll ever have
yes
it's like a world's best coffee sign in
the window and I'm like that's a lie you
can't possibly know that look really
quickly there's a reason for all of this
we have a there's a tweet that I uh saw
that actually had a timeline on it uh
that was I want to bring this up and
then it looks like Josh had gold in his
mind okay you go and then Josh okay see
if you can see if he can pull it up so
there was a timeline to all the
indictments and why they were happening
when they were happening and the most
recent thing is the doj and The
Whistleblower stuff just came out like a
couple of days ago and now we get
another the fourth Trump indictment the
the previous one I think was when Devin
Archer testified we had an indictment a
hunter Biden's case uh he had the
sweetheart deal we had an indictment
right after that like every one of these
has that it's almost like it mirrors you
know when we launched mug Club remember
then when we were coming back announcing
Alex Jones and it's like yes all of a
sudden it's just a whirlwind they just
try to distract you from doing your job
oh by the way just some a little bit of
news that broke I think about 15 minutes
before we came on the air Hunter Biden's
lead attorney has said I want the hell
out of here he went to a federal judge
and said take me off of this case yeah
not kidding attorney that's not a good
look when your head attorney leaves yeah
ever yeah it's never very good not a
good life especially if you're on
attorney like two three and four which
well he'll be very quickly say something
Josh and then no I forgot oh no I said
hold on hold it but I have a head
attorney
something different
completely different right what yeah
it's hard to keep track of so many
indictments at this point so we have a
trump bingo card to help you out yeah
there you go there you go just two more
yeah just two more oh can I predict the
next one
yeah what do you think where do you
think it's next Michigan oh probably I
mean hold on hold on Michigan Michigan
should shut up and just be quiet for a
little while because they they're the
place that I think had an entire County
think they had elected a Democrat or
Republican account which one and they're
like oh wait sorry that's not the wrong
error they flipped like the entire
election it was like a thousand votes in
a very tiny election
a dead guy right they probably someone
Also may have voted from my previous
address where I haven't lived since
2016. somebody may have voted for the
urban farming fields that they have as
well or a sidewalk but we're splitting
hairs they got they got votes from Henry
Ford yes crazy Joe Lewis very
anti-semitic still yeah so anyway you
guys look this is where what it comes
down to the Witch Hunt is going on
comment but it comes down to do you
think that this was the and people will
say you're being black and white right
it's all a or b thinking and I
understand that that's a criticism
leveled against me but
when they meaning the media and the
entire dance when they are saying the
most safe and secure election of all
time I would argue that's an absolute
statement that would require a
counterbalance of an absolute statement
the equivalent to no
Fair uh yeah my counter argument is
I don't know what to what degree because
we won't have the investigations this is
the issue that takes place the media the
government media entertainment
industrial complex they are all one of
the same throw big Tech in there
all of this yeah right and we already
know that the election by the way would
have changed if the hunter Biden
situation had been different just that
one just that one story let alone with
the mail-in ballots let alone with
ballots that disappeared I don't know
all of these sworn affidavits it's very
hard to know if you don't follow up on
them yeah exactly and by the way all the
government doesn't have to win you
remember when Joe Biden said I'm going
to try to cancel student debt but I know
the Supreme Court's pretty much going to
strike it down but at least that'll give
us like a three-month lead time that's
essentially what he said forgiveness he
did it yeah exactly he did it with a
number of things he knows the courts
aren't going to hold this up it does not
matter right guess what Donald Trump has
a limited budget it may be very large he
has a lot of support he has a limited
budget he has limited time to focus on
stuff like this the government does not
it's your tax dollars paying for this
they have an unlimited budget to go
after Donald Trump they have all the
time in the world to stretch this out
yeah I don't need to win comment below
any has any if you're watching right now
have you ever been audited
by the IRS you ever had that ever had to
go through that you have to provide 63
Trader Joe's receipt like it's hiding
money in the Cayman Cayman Islands watch
this I don't think you were doing those
two can O's I don't think that's what
that was this seems like a Swedish
offshore account for four dollars in
dark chocolate salted caramel you
government dick
the point is I've been audited
I thought the point was you're gonna
you're giving me tips on what to get you
for Valentine's Day oh that's true
that's a long way away though we're a
ways off I'm always thinking you've just
got Valentine's chocolate on the mine
oh don't do that no he's already
allergic to crayfish that's mean
by the way uh and another announcement
here before we move on uh to uh we're
going to be discussing Germany what's
happening uh the media wants you to
believe the far right party is rising
not so much and we'll talk about Maui
and some of the conspiracy theories he
has nothing to do with climate change
but we are also announcing the
retirement of the OG mug the ladder with
Crowder mug uh we are launching a new
design it's going to be hand etched in
all the mugs I think we have a picture
because as the mug Club umbrella grows
now it's kind of weird for you to have a
louder with Crowder mug so if you sign
up for Alex Jones Nick depaolo you've
already gotten these mugs yeah um but
that is going to be the new mug design
so once these are gone they're gone you
can sign up now if you want one of the
ogs at letterscrediter.com because we
have to order them by the many many tens
of thousands yes so you can comment
below if you're if you understand I know
some people be upset but do you
understand it
just ask for some just a little bit of
love and understanding I don't want Alex
Jones and Nick to follow and Hodge twins
have a lot of crowder mug that would
make us egotistical pricks
no by the way mugs are shipping out
right now yes they are signed up for my
club we had to order all of them they
take a long time when you're doing like
an initial order pre-orders are easier
but they're shipping out right now so
make sure if you have not entered your
address for shipping and you have
subscribed go and do that now so I can
send you a mug yes all right so we'll
move on to Germany this is always fun
nine
laughs that's what they say when they
see Sam oh
so uh there's a Playbook here here's
what what happens we saw with Donald
Trump and you see this happening in
Germany okay Global leftists right this
is what they do they screw up their
country with terrible policies far left
policies then they watch an opposition
party rise to power and then rather than
address the actual problems they try to
ban their opponents bury their opponents
they try to uh attack and exterminate
them through character assassination
yeah
now thanks to years of horrible policy
again especially and just to be clear by
the way the media is saying far right
right it's a it's called it's Germany's
far-right alternative for Germany afd is
uh sort of the abbreviation there I'm
surprised I put the a that the F in
there the F right yeah yeah it's
alternative for Germany and they put the
effort you just like a d well just be
careful like we're not supporting some
accidental nuts no here's the beauty of
it not the beauty of it but there's
still the Nazi party in Germany oh so
they still have yes these are not them
these are not them these are not them
these people don't like them but how do
we know that yeah yes yes yes we did
learn I just want to make sure I mean
I'm sure they might have an individual
racist who's like sometime Nazi but I'm
saying that
there is still in traffic the Nazi party
okay these are not the this is not the
Nazi party but thanks to yours of
terrible policy especially on
immigration in Germany right now the
alternative for Germany that they are
calling the far right is uh on the rise
Germany's far right is having a great
summer support for the alternative for
Germany is higher than ever before in
their 10-year history
of thuringia one voter in three now
backs the IFD
it was only a local government official
yet the afd is jubilant but the afd is
not just another political party its
members include many far-right
extremists and it is under observation
by the intelligence services for
allegedly undermining democracy so what
explains this there you go the
established parties do a terrible job
and they are getting from bad to worse
by the day by someone made their way up
Central planning a central planning
attitude and that's exaggerated and more
and more people react to it now to be in
the spiritual disclosure some people do
think this is all a conspiracy to just
promote Germany's new Wonder Park uh
Westworld so that does it's just
I don't believe I don't give it Credence
but it's possible now as it relates to
Germany Banning opposition parties who
by the way the second most popular party
in Germany right now pulling at 21 I
know you're saying how does that happen
only 21 well you don't necessarily
understand that this is why we have a
two-party system you can have someone in
Canada for example in the parliamentary
system we have elected with 30 of the
vote because it's so fractured yeah
I do have my reservations though about
Germany um being allowed to really even
be a country um at all I think our our
late friend Norm Macdonald warned us
about this most effectively the only
country that really worries me is uh the
country of Germany
I don't know if you guys are history
Buffs or not but uh
[Applause]
in the early uh part of the previous
Century Germany decided to go to war and
uh who did they go to war with
the world
so and now the leftist Coalition the
German government they want to
completely ban ah this party so
Germany's spy agency
um uh bundes
um it's
bundesprundes uh can you move it a
little more towards me uh boondest
boondest knock Christ ten deenstein
Stitz pool whatever that's fine thank
you
that's my name too
[Laughter]
I knew it I told you they were gonna be
in there now so the German spy agency uh
[Laughter]
they warned the German people against
voting for The afd they're spying the
German spy agency they also by the way
named the the youth Wing uh the young
alternative as this as an extremist
group now keep in mind keep in mind
we're talking about the people in power
in Germany people in power in Germany we
know how they historically have dealt
with those they don't like
oh
back in the house
it's a parliamentary procedure you
wouldn't understand I didn't like
Grandpa anyway politics are foreign to
us in the united we don't know we don't
wear the wigs and stuff like that
um
sorry well by the way speaking about the
afd's rise yeah the researcher uh
Una evona una Ivana tits can you bring
that up again it's a real name it is
it's it's una Ivana tits
I think it's pronounced Boo this is
thank you thank you Kimberly are we
being played right now those are
actually una Ivana tits you can go go
check out all the references are
available a lot of credit we always make
them available just shoot this is from
euronews it says right now they're
garnering a lot of support right now
it's like I'm doing a lot of support on
telegram because they're rallying their
supporters and they're painting
themselves as uh uh if they're paintings
themselves as a persecuted party this in
an unjust system which you're fighting
from this end so that's una Ivana tits
yeah I know I don't like like I've on a
dose tits
your boobs are huge sometimes Trace if
I'm watching Total Recall I like the one
so just to be clear you ask are they
Nazis this is what this party advocates
for okay giving the government uh in
Germany some checks and balances just
like in the United States limiting the
power of the EU over member states and
restricting namely Islamic immigration
into Germany and I know you're going to
say well hold on that part I don't like
the Islamic immigration well hold on a
second again try and see things from you
know they're trying try and walk a mile
in there later hosen why would the
Germans
support a party with a hard line on
immigration
an internal federal police report
described scenes of crying women fleeing
sexual molestation from crowds of men
passes by trying to rescue young girls
from being raped and groups of
intoxicated men throwing bottles and
fireworks at a police force no longer in
control of the situation
here in Germany a suspect is in custody
after a mass stabbing three people died
from their wounds and it leads to five
others were seriously injured police say
they're investigating a possible
islamist Terror motive Witnesses said
the man shouted the Islamic phrase
the attack took place in the southern
state of Bavaria in a Plaza in the
center of the city of würzburg
pedestrians tried to stop the attacker
and may have prevented more bloodshed
the knife man struck in the historic
Center of Wurzburg which was crowded
with Shoppers on a sunny afternoon
authorities say the attacker was a 24
year old that's the most boring news
report how do you make it report about
the stabbing that boring yeah that's
exciting now so you got to give him a
little bit of credit they are kind of
veering away from them
no that's what I'm saying but they're
they're going towards a little bit more
of a calm collected kind of way of
talking to people yes the man was
repeatedly stabbed requesting that he
not be that they could have made it so
much more exciting you know it's a mass
stabbing they're like oh he's running
around he he gets one eins it's fine
then try to push him down some ice yeah
no
unfortunately his demands to not be
stabbed were heard in vain
back to you because he was stabbed was
it clear about that they don't sound
German no so uh by the way the German
president uh Frank Walter stunmeyer said
about the FD we all have it in our hands
to put those who despise our democracy
in their place that's what he says this
is what they always do Donald Trump
despises democracy people who don't
believe in Mass Islamic migration
despise democracy people who don't lock
themselves down and quarantine and
support uh vaccine mRNA injection
mandates
and and by and by the way quarantine
camps in Australia you must hate
democracy you must hate her it's not
it's not our way of life in America and
enough people in Germany are saying this
isn't supposed to be our way of life
that being said I don't take any sides
here uh because I don't think they
should be allowed to be a country
anymore
we'll try to you know fight the world
twice Norm actually goes on and says
they did it again yeah yeah and they did
it again yeah decided to start a war
again the second time and again their
opponent the world
you think it's a hey you know you think
we're gonna win because no it's actually
close it is crazy that they were still
allowed to be a country exactly and I
was like look we're going to divide you
up and give you to other people they
took they took someone else's country
and sent the Jews there right well yeah
and they were like oh you guys can keep
Germany it's fine yeah I don't it's like
no just there should have been a
discussion where it's like well these
things we just have a seat at the table
no you don't you clearly don't you get
nothing exactly perfect and it's not
like I stole your Everlasting Gobstopper
shut up a lot of Jews we'll talk in a
hundred years you guys calm down yeah
you lose so the issue now
you get nothing
[Laughter]
that's it with these cheap suits
you
for me I think that's a new sketch idea
do you Wilder as the as the the main guy
from uh Inglorious Bastards yes the main
investigator
it's not bad so there you go this is the
same Playbook everywhere they did it in
Canada you know where I was raised
they've done it with Donald Trump and
this is why I say it doesn't matter who
you have it doesn't matter if it's
DeSantis it doesn't matter if it could
be Christy the point is they're going to
label any Republican any conservative
they're always going this is their play
You Are An Enemy of the State in Germany
they're going to there's the Nazi party
in Germany by the way National Socialist
just to be clear people don't fully
understand point me to one policy that
would actually be considered
conservative when you say right wing of
the Nazis yeah let's just be let's just
be clear about that but that exists
there
it exists in that country it's kind of
the birthplace of the Nazis
if I may in Germany you may yeah
people Nazis why well because they want
to ban them yeah well it starts like
this you start labeling these other
groups right and you're like oh like you
said it happens in the United States yes
we had President Biden say that Maga was
this threat to democracy the threat to
the country so much so that they need to
make sure that they stack the Supreme
Court so that they can get anything they
want pass through that's that's an idea
that people are like yes of course why
wouldn't we put seven more justices or
whatever the number is to make sure that
we never lose anything again and then
they come after you with the school
board stuff saying oh these white
supremacists go to these school board
meetings and I can't believe and you get
the doj you guys look at this and you
don't study history and understand what
Hitler did was the exact same thing now
he went further obviously his sep that
was a little bit further he goes all
these people that we've said are against
our country I killed them yeah he
literally did this when he took powered
people I did it so that I could save the
country I took this horrible strain on
my body to kill these people and to live
with that idea that I killed these
opposition leaders to say save our
country that's what he did so I don't
know that we have a leader willing to go
that far but you never set the table you
don't allow the table to be set so
somebody can take that final step and go
you know what you've been set up as the
enemy I'm gonna kill you and everybody's
gonna think I'm the good guy for doing
it yeah I'll be the hero exactly yeah
and people trying to make it about race
it's not about race no obviously he hate
but the Jews were a scapegoating he was
deeply anti-semitic personally of course
but they started with the idea of
communicable diseases right for the
greater good we have to get rid of them
for the greater good now I unders
everyone in this country is looking to
try and work on behalf of the greater
good at least that's the platform right
whether the Democrats or Republicans of
course I would say they'll have ulterior
motives yeah but if someone is saying
yeah the greater good involves more
freedom that tends to be how you know
that they're not going the direction of
Hitler if they say yeah well the greater
good is lower taxes being more business
friendly more freedom of choice oh and
by the way we're not going to allow
abortion up until and including birth
generally speaking those aren't the
black hats
but again that's just me Mr
old-fashioned so let's move on here to
and if you're watching on YouTube head
on over to rumble but if you're there
leave a comment because the algorithm
says that we are dead hit the like
button or is it share do we do the share
thing yeah I got the share one hey well
that's on Rumble that's encouraging you
to go to rumble too yeah you can't do it
on you so the Maui fires have you been
following it yes
kind of I have not I didn't know until
we just until yesterday I knew about the
fires but outside of that I whenever I
see a natural disaster I go all right
how long before someone says climate
change and they have no idea it's five
minutes yeah it's immediate it's just
like school shooting you go how long
before it's white supremacy or a gun
thing all right okay and uh it's a
tragedy and I I wish that all I would
have to say is you know my heart breaks
for these people a lot of people have
have died a lot of people have lost
their homes unfortunately we don't have
that luxury in the United States anymore
and then they want to blame you for
polarizing the country if they want to
blame you for fighting back when they
say clearly this is uh this is a
disaster to be blamed on climate change
ah here is their chorus experts warn
that that extreme disasters such as this
one are only becoming more common
because climate change is fueling
stronger storms hotter temperatures more
widespread droughts given what you're
seeing on the ground do you want
President Biden to actually declare a
climate emergency
I think that we we very much need to
acknowledge that climate change is upon
us we're wildfires and all the Canadians
exactly so this is so this brings me to
a clear shift
um doctor and obviously climate change
is a factor but in one way yeah our is
climate change a factor depending on
where you are
yeah it it plays a huge role and it's
one of several causes that multiplies
together to give us the catastrophic
fires that we see today how the deadly
wildfires had spread through Maui came
extra weeks
emergency fuels deadly fires across the
globe if that lady gets a paper cut it's
just baby there's no blood from that
woman's body oh by the way I think that
lady that's that witch definitely put a
spell on Hawaii and get the fire started
yeah she's definitely a witch yeah it
wasn't Oprah she's a wannabe witch where
they're like oh she showed up yeah yeah
go put a hex on that uh whatever so and
spoiler alert no it's not climate change
we'll get into the actual reasons the
truth uh the myths I guess the claims
that they're making very very true easy
yes to go through this very easy to go
through it we'll go through it on mug
Club but Gerald there are also some
other conspiracy theories well and when
I like to say this because the climate
change one is the first and foremost
conspiracy theory about why fires happen
Lord have mercy there's fires on the
planet but there were some other ones
that were a little bit further out there
like this was a directed energy weapon
attack from I believe China also the
interesting one and and maybe I believe
this one even a little bit more than
that one Blackrock in share prices of
Hawaii energy were falling and so these
guys wanted to I think turn this into
like this model Electric City or
something like that and the locals
wouldn't sell and so you know fire yeah
oh yeah no no these are just these are
conspiracy theories of course we're
going to get to the actual facts uh uh
of course that means that we're going to
continue this if you are not a mug Club
member right now lottery.com you get not
only Mud Club you get Nick to Paulo
tonight you get Alex Jones on Friday and
none of this content happens without you
we're going to continue this segment all
the claims and truths and inform you as
to why this fire was clearly caused by
Jewish space lasers YouTube you can piss
off
yes
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]